Ohye: All right.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Maile Ohye, and I'm
a developer programs tech lead
with Google
Webmaster Central.
So today
is gonna be great
because I know all of you
can make a great site for users,
and we're gonna combine
that knowledge that you have
to create a site for users
with new knowledge
about how to create a site
that's search engine smart,
and then
between the two,
you have a really
powerful experience
that can get a lot
of conversions on your site.
So today's goal
for me is actually
to create a really
good environment
where all of you can feel like
we're learning from each other.
So you have questions
that you can ask me,
I have stuff I'm gonna
show you in my slides,
as well as present some examples
of things not to do.
So if you happen
to see something
that you've done before
on the slide,
and you think to yourself,
"Oh, gosh, that's me!"
remember that in this session
there's gonna be no shame.
So you could just
take this lesson learned,
get home, fix it
at some point,
and we're all
gonna move forward.
All right.
So here's to a great
Web experience for all of us.
In the agenda,
first I'll just do an overview,
telling you about
some basic things
about what
I'm gonna talk about.
Next we'll talk about
the size of the Web puzzle.
And what this means is just
how Google's Search engineers
start to understand
how we crawl and index the Web.
And then after that, we'll do
Search friendly development
from start to finish.
So that means
from planning your site.
And that's in italics
because we actually have
a small announcement
to make there.
Then to designing
your site.
Next we'll get
to choosing technologies.
So now that you've
planned a site
and you've started
some site architecture,
you can think about things
like Flash and JavaScript.
Next we'll talk
about making the page.
So what you can put
in the head of your HTML file.
And then adding content
like text, images, and videos,
as well as responding
appropriately
with response codes.
And then engaging
the community.
It's a big presentation,
but if you have questions,
just go up to the mic
and I'll take those at any time.
All right,
so in a nutshell,
if you were to leave
in five minutes
and didn't want to hear these
cool announcements I have,
what I want to let you know is
there's an SEO Starter Guide.
So if you just query
"Google SEO Starter Guide,"
you'll probably
get that.
And it's just
some basic ideas.
After that, read the FAQs
in our Help Center,
verify your site
in Webmaster Tools,
keep your site clean
and secure--secure is a big one.
And then, of course, subscribe
to our blog to get updates.
And then if you have
specific questions,
you can go to our
Webmaster help forum.
And there it's
monitored by Googlers
and also by super users
in our community--
We have some here today--
in over 15 languages.
So that's everything
that you need to do,
but we're gonna
go into
some great detail here
in this presentation.
First, I just need to give a
mention as to what my focus is.
We're gonna be talking
about organic search,
and there's a big
difference between that
and the paid search
that's advertising.
So again,
this is organic search,
where it's free
to participate
and there isn't money
changing hands.
All right, this is the size
of the Web puzzle.
And what this is is a picture
of a globe, the Earth,
which represents
the World Wide Web.
So that's a very vast
Internet and Web experience.
Inside that
we have a subset,
and that's gonna be
the yellow circle.
So the yellow circle
is everything
that Google
is able to crawl,
and we know we haven't
reached the end of the Web yet.
So again, that's a subset
of the entire Web.
And then within that
is what we can actually index
and return
in search results,
And that's
the green segment.
So it's not enough just to make
a site and stick it on the Web.
Right? Because there's
so much out there.
You actually need
to make it crawl-able,
inside that
yellow circle,
and then even furthermore,
return in search results,
you'd have to be
inside the green.
So there's steps you can
take along the way
to make sure that your site
appears in search results.
You can see evidence of this
in Webmaster Tools.
Here if you submit
a site map,
in that red circle,
you'll actually notice
here's all the URLs
we extracted from your sitemap,
but even
a smaller number--
in this case about 700 less,
is what's actually in our index.
So again, we can't
index everything
because a lot of it's
boilerplate
duplicate content
information,
so you really want
to make sure
that we can not only
crawl your site,
but we actually index a large
majority of your good content.
This is what our engineers
have to face.
But let's look
at Webmaster Tools now.
If you haven't verified
your site in Webmaster Tools,
I'd like
to introduce you.
So Webmaster Tools,
this is the audience.
Hello, developers.
This is Webmaster Tools.
Here you have
Message Center,
which is a great way for us
to communicate with you
any notification
we might have.
So one might be, which is
the second notification here,
is that we're actually
telling webmasters
that they have malware.
So again, that's something
you might not know.
You might just kind of someday
realize you have
a malware notice when you
click through to your site.
But you could have
found that out
if your were also verified
in Webmaster Tools.
You can actually verify
multiple sites here.
And verification
is really simple.
It's just an HTML file
in your root directory
or a metatag that you put
on your home page.
All right.
So moving on.
Planning for a new site.
This is very exciting;
it's like planning for a baby.
All right, so full steam ahead
if you have some great idea.
Great ideas would be,
"I have unique content
that I'm gonna create,"
or "I have a compelling
product or service."
Now, unique content
in this example
is my cousin's
wedding blog.
So good for her
for getting online.
Anyway,
she tells you about
the tuxedos
that they're picking out,
and flower arrangements,
which is really exciting
for a lot of people,
and the next part
is just Google,
so if you have a good service,
or you have great content,
look to make a site.
You might want to fine-tune
your business plan, however,
if you're just looking to have
a made for AdSense site,
looking to get clicks.
This is actually
my ex-office mate's site
before I came to Google.
He did a lot of these,
where not much is being said,
he's just trying
to get some ads.
Kind of just pollutes
the Web, I think.
So when it comes to
selecting a domain name,
you want to think about what
you want your site to target.
So there's a lot of ways
you can do this.
If you want to target
international visitors
from all over the world,
you might want to get
something like a .com
or a .net or .info.
Or alternatively,
you can get
the .co.fr versions
of your same domain.
But again there's
a two-pronged approach here.
So know that if you want to get
a ccTLD, country-specific,
then you can only target
users in that region,
at least through Google.
So if you get, like,
an example.com--
I'm sorry--example.fr,
you can't then use that domain
to target users
in the United States.
It's going to be specifically
for a French audience.
The next thing you want
to do is also think about
hosting yourself or hosting on
Blogger, WordPress or AppSpot.
And most cases people say if you
like to get the most authority,
then you're gonna
want to self-host
just to show
your own domain.
And the next part is about
choosing a www
or non-www version
of your site.
And this is important
because of page rank dilution.
You don't want two versions
of your site out there
that people can
link to, you know,
dispersing your links
between two sites.
So...dang.
Page rank dilution.
So again I wanted
to keep this friendly
so that we don't kind of
shame any site,
but I do a simple query
for, like, mobile phones,
and here is one
that comes up.
And I kind of tried
to white out their name,
but obviously
you can see they have
two versions
of the same thing running.
With the geographic target
that we talked about,
you can actually set this
in Webmaster Tools.
So again, if you have
a country-generic TLD,
then you can go ahead
and pull down
to select where
you want it targeted to.
If you're just
targeting users
for a certain language
like Spanish,
then you shouldn't be using
this geographic targeting tool.
It's just for
a specific region.
The next thing you want to do
is determine where to host.
So I wanted
to list this here
just to give you a rundown
of all the factors.
So when you pick a domain, we're
gonna look at different factors
to determine where
you're trying to target.
So first we look at TLD,
as we've talked about.
Next we're gonna look
at whether or not you set
a geographic target
in Webmaster Tools,
and then next we're gonna look
at your Web server's IP address.
So if you give us none
of the other two signals,
then you want
to choose a Web server
and a location where you're
gonna also serve your users.
This can run into problems,
like, say in Europe,
we've seen this before,
where they're hosting
maybe in Switzerland,
but they want to target
users in Spain,
but they've set
nothing else up for us,
so actually that becomes
kind of something
that you might
want to think about
when it comes
to Web server IP.
Another question you might have
is about using shared hosting.
So say you say,
"I'm gonna use shared hosting,
"but I don't trust
anyone else on there.
"There might be spammers there
who're doing bad things,
you know, I might be associated
with bad neighborhoods,"
and that's actually
not the case;
we'll actually
keep those separate.
So if you use
shared hosting, don't worry
about repercussions from other
domains on the same host.
And the next thing.
If you actually
buy your domain
from someplace
like GoDaddy or you use Strato,
they use the Webmaster Tools API
and Access Provider Program.
And what this allows them
to do is automatically,
once you purchase your site,
also verify your site
with Webmaster Tools,
and then give you Clickthrough
to Webmaster Tools
kind of using Google Apps.
So all of that
can be available
if you use something
like GoDaddy.
Which leads me
to the Webmaster Tools API.
So here's our first little
product announcement.
We have a GData API
that currently has functionality
like add and remove sites,
submit sitemaps,
verify your site,
change settings--
a whole bunch
of these things.
But we're adding
more and more on.
What was just recently added
was crawl errors.
And so hopefully
in the future
we'll get this
more and more robust,
and if you're developing sites
for multiple people,
then you can use this
to actually
manage and maintain
these sites
and understand
how they're doing
in search results,
and also with our crawler.
Moving on
to designing your site.
This is a pretty
meaty topic.
We're gonna talk
about site architecture.
This is important
in three main areas.
So users can find
what they want,
so crawlers access
their good-quality content,
and also so that
as a search engine
we index your content
optimally.
So let's talk
about first for users.
A big thing
is navigation.
So you want
easy navigation
for your users
in these three main areas.
First, when they come
to your site,
they can determine
their location.
What helps with that
are things like breadcrumbs.
Right, if they clicked
a link from somewhere else,
to, let's say,
women's high heels,
they want to know "what category
is this and how did I get here?"
So breadcrumbs give them a good
indicator of where they're at.
Next a user's
probably going to ask
about "where do
I want to go?
I know where I want to go--
how do I get there?"
And you want to help your users
get where they want to go.
So things that are helpful
are a search box,
logical category
navigation,
and also think about
if they come to a child page,
how can they get back
to the home page?
Or if they come
to your home page,
how can they get
to the appropriate child page?
You also want to let them know
what they've already visited.
And this comes
in the form of links
that are colored
when they're visited,
also in maybe things like
"Items you've also looked at."
So that's for users
in terms of navigation.
Now for users
for URL structure.
Shareable URLs
are always good.
So that I can have a URL,
I can give it
to my friend through email,
and they can find
the exact same item.
Descriptive filenames also help
users as well as search engines.
So you have keywords here
separated by hyphens,
like "g1-phone."
And then, of course,
you have lowercase URLs
for the safest
implementation.
Meaning that users
might manually
type this into their browser;
it's easier if it's lowercase.
Also if it comes
to wanting to block content.
Keep in mind that "Robots.txt"
is case sensitive,
so it's harder to do
combinations of every word
if you're using a "Robots.txt"
file with mixed case.
Now let's get into site
architecture for search engines.
You want to
first think about
what's gonna be
private versus public,
and secure
that private data.
When it comes to having a site
that has adult content,
think about separating
adult content
from family-friendly
content.
And this is because
for things like SafeSearch,
it's much easier
for us to filter
if we see a directory structure
that's logical.
So I don't know
who does adult sites,
but go ahead and separate
that between the two.
And of course,
for search engines,
static links are
always best, right,
because we can follow those,
and they have good anchor text.
Keep important pages
well-linked from the home page.
This means don't hide it
in some child leaf node;
if it's a really
important product,
bring that up and link it
from the home page.
And of course
submit a sitemap.
These are xml sitemaps,
often from sitemaps.org,
followed by Yahoo!
and Microsoft and Ask.
Okay, so now we're gonna
get some fun stuff
like what can
I disallow, right?
Again we have that
size of the Web problem
where there's all that
content out there,
then there's
some content we crawl,
and then
some content we index.
You don't want to get us stuck
crawling stuff that's not good.
So you can actually
disallow shopping carts
if you happen to be doing
this type of implementation.
Because Googlebot will never
go through your site
and actually
purchase books
and give that conversion
that you want.
So go ahead and disallow
things like shopping carts.
Login pages as well.
He forgot his username.
He probably won't be logging in.
And you can test
all these types of disallows
through the Robots.txt
generator
and testing tool
in Webmaster Tools.
So here you can test everything
before it goes live,
as well as help create
a Robots. txt file.
All right,
so this is kind of fun,
but we're gonna talk
about Dynamic URLs.
And the reason
I want to do this is because
I'm gonna channel people
from my crawl team here
who have had
serious headaches
when dealing
with things like this.
I'm sure most of you
create sites
that are dynamic
and not static-based,
so let's talk
about this for a while.
Dynamic URLs
are often recognized
by name/value pairs,
right?
So you have a name
like "category"
and a value being "1."
A name "answer,"
value equals "10."
Often we see this
through cookies,
so, you know, it's hidden
for the user details,
but if you want your site to be
accessible without cookies,
with cookies disabled,
then of course
you're gonna have to go
back to these dynamic URLs.
A great practice
for our crawl team and for us,
and to make sure
that we understand your site,
is to create algorithmically
easily understood--
i.e. standard--
dynamic URL structures.
So take a look at this.
We have four URLs here,
and they're all actually
gonna lead to the one
product page for the G1 phone.
But they differ
in terms of
different parameters
set on there,
like "category"
as well as "affiliateid"
and the two
the "affiliateid" changes.
So you might have a site
that has 1,000 products.
You might have ten URLs
that could actually link
to each product.
So now you've created
a site with 10,000 URLs,
and actually you only have
1,000 good product pages.
Now Google comes along,
and we see that you have
10,000 URLs, right?
But we can't crawl
all the Web.
We're trying to limit
our resources
and crawl what's useful.
So given a list
of 10,000 URLs,
what we're gonna do is we use
our algorithms to understand.
What's an important parameter?
What's an irrelevant parameter?
And we go through,
and go through.
So we might start
to see "category=mobile"
didn't change this that much--
the content much.
So "category," let's think
about that not being relevant.
"Affiliateid" and then "1234,"
"affiliateid=5678"
didn't change at all.
Let's definitely
throw that out.
So we start with 1,000,
we start to prune that down
as we see what becomes relevant
and what becomes irrelevant.
So when you stick with these
types of standard formats,
if you want to be
found in search engines,
this is much easier
for us to process.
Right, because we're not gonna
go out and crawl all 10,000,
we're gonna find out
ways to just crawl
the most important
of those.
So when we do crawl, you want us
to crawl your important content
so that we can index that and
return that in search results.
So this is great.
The one reason why people might
not have done this in the past
is they thought
ranking reasons.
They thought, oh, I need to put
keywords in my path
because that's better for
ranking, which isn't the case.
We'll actually interpret
keywords from whether they're
in the path or within
the actual name value here.
So if you have a G1 phone that
you're hoping can rank for this,
either place is actually
gonna be fine for ranking,
but in terms of how
we process your URLs
that second example
with the standard pair
is actually easy for us.
So we're more likely to find
more of your good content
and not spend time crawling
your duplicate content.
All right, so,
my girlfriends and I
tend to call
things "mavericks"
when it's not
what we want.
And so one way
we're gonna look at this
is called "maverick
alternative encodings."
So these are developers
who thought,
you know what, I'm not gonna
stick with the standard.
No, no, no, I'm gonna
try something new.
And this is really hard,
from a search engine
perspective, to process
because we can't apply
our algorithms anymore.
So in this case, this company
decided to do their own encoding
where "W0 = ?"
and "QQ = &."
Again, if we see
10,000 URLs
and they only have
1,000 products,
we can't make out
which ones to crawl.
This all looks like
static URLs, right?
We can't see anything different
between the two.
Luckily we were able
to diagnose this,
but you could see
from your standpoint,
you really don't want
to leave that in our hands
to have to make
those type of decisions.
This is fairly
tough to do.
So some other examples.
People putting
session I.D.s
in their path
or in some positional value.
Again this creates
an infinite space.
So we can't start
narrowing down
from 10,000 to 2,000
to 1,000 URLs.
If you put your session I.D.
in the middle of the path,
which I think was a default for
some Web servers, unfortunately,
that looks pretty
infinite to us.
We're not gonna
be able to know
that that's actually
not valuable.
And then some people do it
as positional value,
where you're
the only developer
who knows it's gonna
be like this.
It's really hard again
as a search engine
to understand
what's actually valuable here.
Again, think about it
from our perspective.
If you want to be found
by a search engine,
and we need to be able
to process this algorithmically.
I have a few other
cute ones.
Okay, this is my favorite.
[laughs]
I don't know if this developer
is out there wearing some badge
of, like,
"yeah, I did it,"
because what they've done here
is done category navigation,
but with this binary encoding
of what's expanded
and what's collapsed.
[laughs]
Okay, now let's put on your
search engine cap again.
From our perspective,
our crawl team wants to crawl
every category page,
and every leaf node page.
We don't want to spend time
having everything expanded
and not knowing to get
to your leaf node pages.
Because there's
so many URLs now.
We can't make this out.
So some good tips are
if you have, you know,
a lot of navigation, maybe just
expand one category at a time
or maybe there's
other things you can do,
but the idea here
is keep it standard
so that we don't have to
deal with something like this.
All right, so know that
from Google's perspective
we really want
to help you out.
We really are trying
to crawl this.
That's why we've kind of
diagnosed some of these sites.
So if you verify your site
in Webmaster Tools,
we'll actually give you
an infinite space notification
if we think that
you've got a problem.
And this can be things
like calendars or this type
of positional encoding
that you've seen earlier.
So in this example
we're actually
sending you
a message that says,
"Googlebot found
an extremely high number
of URLs on your site."
And then we give you
ways to diagnose that.
All right,
so now I want to talk
about indexing
and URL structure.
You want to have
pretty sweet anchor text.
So if I'm Webmaster Tools,
I'm linking to our blog.
You can see here
my anchor text actually says,
"Webmaster Central Blog."
What you don't want
is something like "click here"
because that's
not descriptive.
Okay, now let's get
into choosing technologies
and here
is where we have
some cool product
announcements as well.
First with technologies,
always remember,
HTML is your friend.
Progressive enhancement's
always a good way to go.
So there's
a lot out there,
but HTML is access--
you know, can be seen
on a lot of devices,
whether it's a desktop
or mobile phone.
On top of which you'll just
reach the largest audience,
it'll be crawled well
by search engines--
that's pretty given--
and then
with progressive enhancement,
you can add this other stuff
later, right?
So you still might add AJAX,
or you might want Flash,
but you can do that in addition
to your beautiful static HTML.
All right, so moving on
to something like JavaScript.
Here's something cool
that we just
want to let you know
up front here about our status.
We're actually innovating all
the time with our crawl team,
and we can now process
"onclick" events.
So what this means for you
is that if you had a site
that didn't have
some URLs indexed
because it was
JavaScript executed,
Now we actually hopefully can
reach more of your good content.
So know that this functionality
is being continuously updated.
We're not in
the perfect state,
but we just want to make you
aware of what's going on.
So how are we
doing this?
We're actually constructing
a page much like the browser;
we have a lot
of the dom structure there,
and we're adding things like
the link tags and form elements
to find some of these
onclick events.
We can also do an onclick
if it calls a function
and creates a URL,
or an anchor,
but only if that function
is defined on the page itself.
We are not at the point where we
can externally load resources.
So to give you
a better idea,
I'll just have you
look at some of these.
So these are examples
that we are now
able to process
from your site.
So again this is Google's
new capability
with JavaScript onclick.
You can see here
there's "window.opens,"
calling functions,
stuff like that.
All right,
let's talk about AJAX.
so while we could do
some of this stuff
with JavaScript,
we're not yet there
with AJAX.
Kind of those RPC calls
and such going on,
we're not at that point.
So if it's important to you
to get your AJAX site crawled,
then you're still gonna want
to do something like Hijax
where you create a static link
in addition to your AJAX.
Something we're working on,
but we're not there yet.
Again, we're just letting you
know about JavaScript.
If you have questions
you guys can go up to the mics.
For sure, any time.
All right, for Flash.
So you might have seen
this announcement before,
we have more
to say, though.
We can find
all the user-visible text
in a Flash file.
So we're actually going through,
executing buttons,
doing things like that.
And we can associate the text
we find with your file itself.
So if you don't want text found,
then put it in an image,
'cause we won't still capture
text in images.
Other things
to know about this
is that it's been
a huge boon to our users.
Before, we had no snippets
showing for Flash files,
we just had the title,
and now they see
something much prettier.
You can embed your Flash
using the standard techniques
like SWFObject
and SWFObject2,
but our big announcement here is
that previously we couldn't load
external files
into your Flash file.
But now we're actually able to
associate any external files--
externally loaded files,
and actually bring that in
with the Flash itself.
So again that's
a big improvement for us
in terms of
calling Flash.
So we have two big announcements
here with our crawling team.
We have JavaScript onclick
as well as this ability
to use externally loaded
resources.
A big thing
that I think
they talk about
at developer conferences
are frames and iframes.
So I just wanted to cover
how we deal with these
from a crawl and index
perspective.
Frames and iframes
can all be discovered
at crawl time
within the parent page.
So you don't have to
have a separate link
to the frame or iframe;
we'll actually interpret it
within that parent page.
When it comes
to indexing, though,
there's gonna be
a slight differentiation.
Frames will be processed
with the parent,
while iframes will actually
be treated in index
as a separate URL.
And the reason that's the case--
Go ahead.
The reason that's
the case is because
historically we've seen
a lot of ads in iframes,
and so there was
no use to actually
bring that into
the parent page.
Yes.
audience member:
[indistinct]
If you have content
on that site--
on your site,
that people are using,
their friends are
chatting about stuff,
all of that information
that people are chatting about
you will not--
that stuff won't
be indexed by Google?
Ohye: Most likely not
with Friend Connect.
And also do you
have to be logged in
for a majority of that,
or is it public?
audience member: Y--
Ohye: Okay,
so this person says
you can see
the discussion, but...
Okay, I think
with Friend Connect
that we're still
not processing that content.
audience member: Okay.
Ohye: Yeah.
But we can look
to do more of this,
this is just our current
treatment of iframes.
But thanks.
So this is kind of
a big topic within our team--
is what we're gonna do
with some of the things
like Friend Connect.
Okay, so now let's talk
about making the page.
We've talked about
selecting a domain,
we've talked about
site architecture,
choosing technologies,
and now we're just gonna
actually make the page.
So using your head.
So all these things we're gonna
put in the head of our file.
Or we can.
but first of all, let's look at
what a search result looks like.
All right,
so there's a title,
and that corresponds to
the title of your page, right?
There's a snippet,
which could either be found
within the context of your page
or used from a meta description,
which is, again,
in the head of your page.
Then there's the URL
as well as sitelinks.
And those sitelinks are
calculated algorithmically,
done especially
if you have a site
that's very accessible
to search engines.
And it's gonna be
the high result.
So looking at titles.
You want to create
unique titles
as well as descriptive
meta descriptions.
Again, because they can be
used in a snippet.
So here's an example
of a meta description.
[reads portion
in pink box]
Again, it's not too long,
which is good,
and it gives the user
a good snippet,
should this be shown
in search results.
The next thing you could put
in your head is rel="canonical."
Have any of you heard
about rel="canonical"?
Okay, okay.
A few people. All right.
So what this is--
Oh! Sorry, before I get
on to that.
Here's an
informative title.
I recently had
a hair salon mistake,
and so if I were to search
for "grow healthy hair,"
something I could see here
is that these titles
actually contain
my keywords, right?
So it's good to have
these unique titles.
Again, "untitled"--
not informative.
All right, so in terms of titles
and meta descriptions,
you can use
Webmaster Tools.
This is gonna point out to you
where you have duplicate titles,
or duplicate meta descriptions,
or titles that don't exist.
So rel="canonical."
Again, we talked about
all those dynamic URLs
and something
you might have been asking
is that it's creating
a lot of duplicate content.
Right, these three URLs
go to the same page.
What this means is that
you might be losing page rank.
So before
you had 20 links,
now there's being dispersed
ten to the first URL,
five people are linking
to the second,
five to the third.
So what you can do here
is add to the head section
of your duplicate,
and even your canonical version,
this rel="canonical."
And this is actually
gonna tell us--
search engines
being Google;
also Yahoo! and Microsoft have
agreed to accept this standard--
what you want as the canonical
version of your URL.
So now all those properties
from the duplicates
will be transferred
to your canonical version,
and your canonical URL will also
be shown in search results.
So you can let us
try to do
this clustering
and dupe detection on our own,
or of course you could set that
yourself with rel="canonical."
Okay, before
I get to adding content,
nobody has questions
if you want to go to the mic?
Good? Yeah.
audience member: You were
talking about the number of--
extremely large number
of links on your site.
What is that number?
What is--what do you consider
extremely large?
Ohye: So yeah,
usually that has to do
with something
that's nearly infinite.
Meaning like a calendar
that's going on and on.
Or like the positional
encoding.
audience member: So, like,
30,000 isn't a lot.
Ohye: Oh, that is a lot.
Yeah.
But, you know, if we detect that
you don't have that much content
and we are
seeing that much,
we'll trigger
that note to be sent.
audience member:
Okay. Thank you.
audience member: On the
canonical naming portion of it,
is that limited just
to a single domain?
So if you have multiple domains
pointed to the same Web site,
can you point to
the root domain as opposed to
the one that is being
indexed at the time?
Ohye: No, you need to--
It only works
within the same domain.
audience member: Okay.
Ohye: Yes?
audience member: Onto your topic
of session I.D.s,
I've had trouble with the
session format that Java uses.
It's a semicolon
followed by a session I.D.,
and it seems that Google
often indexes all of those,
it's not recognizing that
as a session I.D.
Ohye: Okay.
Do you have a domain example?
I can bring that back
to our team.
audience member: It'll just
be J SESSION I.D.--all caps.
And anyone who's
used Tomcat or--
Ohye: Oh, I mean
do you have a domain
that actually
shows this problem?
audience member: This particular
form of session I.D.
is often added
by your container,
so you'll have a Web site that
doesn't have sessions at all,
but when Google comes along
and crawls it,
it'll get a session I.D.
if you happen to be
using Tomcat and Java.
Ohye: Yeah, I got you.
But do you just have
one example that I can just
make sure I take back to them
where you're like,
"Here's a problem I've seen
on this site"?
audience member:
Citycarshare.org
has that problem.
Ohye: Citycarshare?
audience member:
Citycarshare.org.
Ohye: Great. ".org."
audience member: .org.
Ohye: Okay. Perfect.
You guys, I'd love
to get more feedback
on some stuff
that you see.
'Cause you're the best audience
to get this from,
so let me know.
Yes.
audience member: I had one quick
question about the Flash.
You were talking about that text
is indexed by Google now.
Is it all text,
or just selectable text?
Ohye: It should be all text.
audience member: All text.
Ohye: That's visible to the user
and not in an image.
audience member: Okay.
Ohye: Thanks.
audience member:
I have a question
regarding
the Webmaster Tools.
You pointed out
that if you wanted
a U.K. site,
for instance--
Ohye: If you wanted a what?
A U.K. site?
audience member:
If you wanted a site
that's targeted towards
a U.K. audience,
are you better off
using a ".uk"?
Basically right now
we have a .com,
which is doing pretty good,
and I was wondering
if we should get a uk.xyz.com
to target
the U.K. content, or--
Basically currently our target
is the North American market.
Ohye: So you're thinking
about a subdomain?
audience member: Yeah,
so should we use uk.xyz.com,
or should we say
xyz.co.uk?
Which would be
a better option?
I mean, this one already
has a lot of authority
with Google and I guess
other search engines.
So would I be better off going
with a subdomain on this one,
or just go to a completely
different TLD?
Ohye: Yeah, those are hard--
those are tough questions.
It kind of matters also
for your marketing team.
If you have a subdomain,
are you looking
to target a bunch of other
subdomains, other countries?
audience member:
Eventually, I guess.
Ohye: Okay, so here's
the thing.
I mean, you could
do studies on this.
You have to--It's a hard
decision to make.
But essentially
a user in the U.K.--
He wants his site
to appear for this user.
If they see a .co.uk,
they automatically know
it's tailored to them, right?
They're used to seeing
that extension of the TLD.
If they see a subdomain,
are they as likely to see it?
I don't really know.
But from a ranking
perspective,
we can target
both of those to that area.
So if you do a subdomain,
then you're gonna want to verify
that in Webmaster Tools,
and it'll be targeted
to users in the U.K.
If you do
the cc TLD.co.uk,
it'll automatically
target those users.
So we won't treat it
as the same domain, necessarily,
if you use it
as a subdomain.
Both are kind of
viable options.
audience member: I see,
but you'd be able
to use the Webmaster Tools
to say--to choose--
I saw your drop-down box
first thing.
This one should be targeted
to such and such audience.
So can I do that
with subdomains as well?
Ohye: Yes. A verified subdomain
or sub directory.
audience member:
Oh, beautiful.
Ohye: So you could
say uk.xyz.com
targets
the United Kingdom.
audience member: And just
a quick comment,
regarding the onclicks.
I know it's not
a new thing;
you guys have been doing that
for about a year.
We started noticing that
on my site a year ago.
Because we were--
basically didn't want Google--
We have a lot
of inventory pages.
We didn't want Google
to target that.
One day we realized
that your search engines
were just coming in
and going past the onclicks.
'Cause that was
our Robot.txt.
So it's been
going on for a while.
Ohye: Okay, yeah,
I think we're letting you know
about our status.
We kind of, as they say, turned
the jets on just recently,
but yeah, we were
trying to experiment.
Yes?
audience member: Do you know
if .ws domains are generic,
or if they are
country-targeted?
'Cause I know those have been
released publicly recently.
Ohye: .us?
audience member: .ws.
Ohye: Oh, I'm not sure
what that corresponds to.
audience member: Yeah,
it was a national code,
but I think now it's
just for "Web site."
It's kind of like
the .tv and stuff.
Ohye: I think we would
probably take
the official version
of what that corresponds to.
I mean, I could check that out.
.ws?
audience member: Yeah.
Ohye: Okay.
audience member:
And then, um--
Ohye: Sorry I don't
know all my TLDs.
audience member: And then
can you override that
with the targeting
in Webmaster Tools?
Ohye: If it's a .ws?
audience member: Yeah, if it--
Ohye: If it's considered a GTLD,
you'll have that pull-down.
If it's not, then you won't
be able to pull that down.
audience member: Oh, okay,
then I think it is.
'Cause I've seen it
on there before.
All right. Thanks.
Ohye: All right.
So we'll move on
to the next section.
So this is about
adding content.
So we'll start first
with just text.
I don't like to get
into this keyword talk,
but keywords
are important.
If you want to rank
for a certain word,
you should use it
in your text naturally.
One of my friends
often jokes
that he worked
for a shoe company
who wanted to say--they said,
"We don't call it running shoes,
we call it
athletic footwear."
And that's great, they can call
it whatever they want,
but you want to adopt
the language of your users,
and it's not often
that I would type,
when I look for running shoes,
"athletic footwear," right?
So a great thing to do
is really use
the keywords that people
will search for.
Of course be readable
and natural.
You know, keyword stuffing
is spamming users,
it's spamming
the search engines.
Now if you want
to add images.
Just some tips for you.
For Image Search,
here are some of the signals.
We're gonna look at the text
surrounding the image,
so having good text as well as
good headings is helpful
to help us understand
what your image is about.
Additionally, the quality
of the image matters.
So you don't want
anything placeholder,
You don't want anything
low resolution.
Really quality images are what
we want to return to users.
And another part is about
image attributes like alt text.
This is a great thing to add.
We look at this very well.
In fact, if you have
just an image link,
we'll actually use the alt text
as your anchor text.
so alt text
is very important.
And of course
good filenames.
I don't know if you've seen
the Lolcat invisibl olimpiks.
It's hilarious.
But you want to use filenames
that are hyphen-separated
versus the camera default,
right, which is, like, DSC.
audience member:
One question.
Ohye: Sure.
audience member:
You mentioned hyphen twice.
What about
the underscore?
Is that worse?
Ohye: Yes, it is
a little worse. Yeah.
Hyphens will be automatically
seen as word separators,
whereas
underscores are not
seen as a full-strength
word separator.
Okay.
So I've been saving this one
to talk to developers
because a lot of SEOs
know not to do this,
and the developers
are the only people I think
that are really savvy enough
to know to do this.
But it's not a good idea
if you want to be found
in search engines.
And the idea is they think,
oh, you know what,
I've got these images
that have some text in it,
so to let search engines
know about my text,
I will actually
use "text-indent: -999."
So we all know
what this does, right?
It's gonna push it off
the screen so no one can see it.
But being a search engine,
we understand that happens.
So let me just tell you
why this is a bad idea.
The reason why it's bad
is because this is
a long-time-been-around
spam technique.
People love this.
They put white on white text.
You know, that's
kind of hidden text.
In this case they're trying
to put it off the screen.
So we can find
tons of examples of this.
Again, I don't want
to, like, shame anybody,
but this site, you know,
obviously did text-indent: -999.
And then they just put a whole
bunch of links at the bottom.
Right? Try to, like, boost
their links to other sites.
Spam. Penalty.
You know, not gonna do well.
So if you want
to do image replacement, it's--
I mean, if you want to just--
if you're using images,
use alt text if possible.
If not, try to do things
like sifr, sprites.
Even less to a degree is
something like <noscript>,
but again,
alt text is best,
then something
like sifr and sprites.
Text indent--risky.
Okay. Just want
to make that clear.
You can do it, but if you care
about your rankings,
not a great idea.
All right.
Again, just to let you know,
we're trying to serve our users,
but we also
care about you, for sure.
So we actually will
send messages if we think
that you're a legitimate site
doing something like this.
So here's an example of a hidden
text message in Message Center.
Well, we let you know that
we detected some of your pages
using techniques
outside our guidelines,
and we go on.
Again, we really just want
to help you out here.
Now for videos.
this is all
fairly basic SEO stuff.
But if you have videos, YouTube
does a lot of good things.
They have static
HTML navigation,
text descriptions,
good titles,
you can visibly see
the popularity of a video,
so you can see the views,
you can see the ratings.
They have comments
that help users become engaged.
Comments can also be a turnoff,
but, you know,
it also keeps
the people there.
They have related videos
that you can see
that keeps it sticky
on the site,
so you keep
looking at more.
Which I think
we've all done.
Like, an hour passes, and you're
like, what am I doing?
And of course the best thing
about video optimization
is to create
a compelling video.
One that people
do want to share.
And if you're hosting on your
own, uptime is important.
That's why YouTube kind of
does so well, and Metacafe.
These are sights that
we can rely on the up time
when we show them
in search results to users.
Yes.
audience member:
Hey.
We wanted to--We see that if you
have a site
that's targeting, say,
U.K. audience,
and you have--
Sorry.
And you have your servers
in U.K., it tends to do better
on search engines,
and that's fine.
We can also rent
a server in the U.K.
But we're trying to go to see
the ends and to the cloud,
and we're very much wondering
how Google would treat
if the whole site
is hosted on the cloud, say.
I mean, would they
actually say
that it was meant
for a U.K. audience.
Ohye: Yeah.
Again, the webserver IP--I mean,
that might be your experience
that your ones that are hosted
in the U.K. do better,
but that might not be
the actual factor.
It could be a lot of factors
that lead to it doing better.
So again, Web server IP,
I just mentioned that
because it's--
it's a very tertiary
signal, though.
Again, first we're
gonna look at TLDs,
and then wherever
you host it,
whatever cloud
it happens to be in,
you could actually target that
in Webmaster Tools, right?
So those are gonna be
two strong signals.
Web serv IP--
I'm just mentioning it
because as you choose to host,
I want you to know
that that could
be a factor.
But if you have the other two
covered, then you'll be fine.
Yeah, you mentioned
about the text indent thing
to basically
hide content.
Ohye: Yeah.
audience member:
What about all the--
I know for our site we have
a lot of content that might be
in, like, coda sliders
or, you know,
potentially an accordion
so it's visibility hidden
or you know,
what have you--
Ohye: Display none
or something.
audience member: How do you--
how would you ever discern
between, you know,
legitimacy there and...
Ohye: Okay,
so another great thing
about talking
to developers is that
almost they're
always legitimate.
Which is good.
So, you know, we realize
that that's a lot--
that a lot of code on the Web
does stuff like that.
That uses display none,
visibility hidden.
It's not something
we're looking to penalize.
But we do think
that there are other ways
if you can figure out
other ways.
But in some cases
that's all you can use.
And I think you'd
probably notice
that those sites aren't hurt
in rankings, by any means,
because we're aware
of stuff like that.
I think text indent to us
is just usually so flagrant.
I mean, you might be
doing it for a good reason,
so if you're doing
text-indent: -999,
we're not saying, like,
take a whip to all those sites;
they're going down.
That doesn't
happen like that.
We actually
evaluate all of them,
but that just becomes a signal
that you're gonna be flagged.
We consider that
fairly risky.
So it's not a determinant
of being penalized,
but it's just something
we want to discourage.
Yes?
audience member: Do pages
in the root directory
get a higher
page rank priority
than anything
under a subdirectory?
Ohye: Uh, no,
they don't.
I think the only problem
that you might see--
I mean,
this isn't ranking,
you probably won't
see a problem,
but from users' perspectives,
if you go on and on and on
in every subdirectory, then you
might have some problems there.
They might be less likely to
share that link with each other.
Therefore you'll have
less link love.
Page rank
can be affected.
So it's still good
to keep them fairly short.
But, you know,
getting beyond, say, ten
kind of becomes
hard to handle.
One thing about videos
I wanted to mention as well
is video sitemaps.
So this isn't
part of sitemaps.org yet,
but you could submit
a video sitemap to Google,
giving us a list of your URL,
the thumbnail, and description,
and then we can use that
as we process your videos too.
Okay, so responding
appropriately.
What this has to do with
is response codes.
So we've got our domain,
we're setting it up,
we chose technologies, you know,
we've put stuff in the head,
and now we're
gonna talk about
how do we respond
to get requests?
So here are
the key response codes.
200s--That's your URL exists,
that's straightforward.
We don't want you to serve 200
if it's actually a 404.
That's called
a "soft 404."
A lot of times
people do that
and redirect it
to their home page
or try to do
something like that.
In those cases, again,
we're crawling,
and we're just seeing
more duplicates,
so there's no need
to really do that.
Just go ahead and serve
a 404 when it 404s.
301--This is important
if you have content
that you actually want
to change the URL for.
A 301's gonna do that
because it'll say,
"301 says it's
moved permanently."
So essentially
we'll say,
take everything from this source
and move it to this target.
So search results will have this
target URL and not the source,
so that happens
with a 301.
And all that link popularity
goes from A to B.
404: File not found.
Same to us as a 410.
I often get
into discussions
where, like,
"But 410 means gone!"
and I just don't want
to do that here.
So now we treat that
the same as a 410.
And if you're gonna do
temporary site maintenance,
some things that
we've seen developers do
is, oh, I'm gonna robot out
my site right now,
or I'll no-index everything
because I want to
bring it down for a day.
Or maybe they'll say,
I'm gonna serve 404s everywhere.
And that's actually
not our preferred method
because a 404 signals to us
that it's not around, right?
If you give us a 503
when you do this,
then we'll know to come back
and check it again.
So if you bring
your site down,
go ahead and give us
a 500 response code.
All right, this is
one of my favorite--
maybe my favorite
feature.
I'm gonna go with favorite--
in Webmaster Tools.
And what this is
is crawl errors.
And so actually, well,
the next slide is my favorite.
Sorry.
Here we'll show you
response codes for URLs
that we've had
problems with.
And you can just go ahead
and verify this.
So there's things like
URLs that are unreachable,
URLs that timed out.
If you have
hosting problems
you can kind of notice
some of that here.
That you'll have a lot
of time outs or something.
Okay, this is
my favorite feature.
Now what it is
is crawl error sources.
So it's part of
this big movement--
I don't know if you've heard--
about cleaning up the Web.
And what you can do now
is fix broken links.
So inside your site,
if it's verified,
and we can
show you crawl errors,
now when you have a 404, we'll
actually tell you for each URL
where it was linked from,
or that that's an internal link
or an external link.
See, that's
pretty powerful
because now
you can actually
figure out more about
who's linking to you,
you could say--you can reach out
and say, "Hey, you know--"
You could improve
your user experiences.
"This is actually
the URL of my content,"
or, you know, "you misspelled
this, or you mistyped this.
"Let's go ahead
and clean that up
so they can come straight
to what you wanted."
I think this will be fun
because I think
kind of that seamless
Web experience
would be really
fun as a user.
So you can go ahead
and clean up your 404s
through
crawl error sources.
audience member: Question.
Ohye: Yes.
audience member: I've been using
the Webmaster Tools,
and I noticed that I have some
crawl errors on external links,
and, you know, I don't know
who these people are
who linked to me,
and they put in mistakes.
How can I get them corrected
or eliminated from--
Ohye: Okay.
Got it. Did everyone
hear that question?
So one answer,
of course, is money.
No, I'm just kidding.
What you usually do, I mean,
most people have, right,
like "admin @ the address"
and you can go ahead
and email that.
That's kind of a--
or "webmaster @."
That's one good way
to try it out.
That's kind of the approach
that we usually use
to try to email people
when we have messages
and they're not verified
in Webmaster tools.
In the past we've just tried
to do those admin or webmaster.
Some default
email address.
audience member:
So it's up to me
to correct it
with people linking.
I can't just say
this or that.
It may not
stay eliminated.
Ohye: No, it'll still
exist on their site, right?
audience member: What about
creating a rule
in your .htaccess
that redirects
the bad adverts
to the good adverts?
Ohye: Okay. Got ya.
So this questioner asked--
good question, thank you.
He asked, "Can I redirect that
404 to the appropriate page?"
Of course.
In that case,
that's not a soft 404, right?
You're actually saying, here's
what they actually wanted,
let's go ahead
and fix that.
You could do that
as well,
but for me I kind of like
getting it to the source,
like making
that relationship
and figuring out
what they wanted.
But I'm a connection
person.
So, yeah.
audience member:
I see that Google
is real slow
with the 301s.
If you put a 301 on some pages,
it takes Google up to a month,
or a long time,
to get to it,
and I always wondered
if I could put that in my XML.
We have, usually, like,
a few hundred pages like that.
So should I put that
in the Google XML sitemap,
and with the updated date,
so that--
because that it reads
every few hours.
And would there be a penalty
if I did--took that approach?
It seemed a little risky
so I never tried it.
Ohye: I think in your sitemap,
too, you'd probably
want to put the source URL,
not the target, if you're--
so that we crawl the old one
and know that it 301s.
audience member:
That's what I mean.
Ohye: Okay, so I think
the reason why the 301s
might not be taking
as quick effect
is usually because we haven't
crawled that content as readily,
and it's just not getting
through our index as quickly.
So if, like, you have
a news site, right,
we actually crawl
and index news really fast
because it has to be shown
to users really quickly.
So we'll pick up
things like 301s
for those quick crawls
that are quickly--
always modified
fairly quickly.
If you have static content
that you just changed,
it is gonna take a while
before we crawl it,
and then before it
gets through our pipeline.
audience member:
Yeah, I guess my question is--
Ohye: "Can you
speed it up?"
audience member:
Ye--No, no, no, not quite that.
Would Google think
that I'm, like, fooling the bot
by saying that this page
is changed in the XML sitemap
and all the change
has been is a 301 to the--
301 to another page?
Ohye: No.
audience member: No?
That'd be all right?
Ohye: Yeah. That's fine.
audience member: Since
the sitemap XML was mentioned,
are you gonna
talk about it?
Or relations between it
and of the, you know,
just regular pages, or sometimes
people do sitemap in HTML?
What's the relations
between those?
Ohye: Sure, I'm not
gonna talk about it,
but I will
now that you asked.
Okay, there's different
types of sitemaps you can have.
There's lowercase "sitemap"
with lowercase S,
which is like
an HTML sitemap, right?
Where you click on a tab
and it says "sitemap,"
and it shows you
the links
and some type of navigation
scheme, group, somehow.
What we're talking about--
that's good for users.
And search engines
can follow that as well,
but what we're talking about
is an XML sitemap,
or just a sitemap that is
purely based for search engines.
And you can
create this sitemap
and submit it through
Webmaster Tools,
or you can ping Google
or ping Yahoo!
or ping Microsoft
with that URL.
Additionally you could put this
XML sitemap for search engines
in your Robots.txt file.
So as you have all these
disallowed rules,
you could also
put "sitemap:"
and then the URL
to your Robots.txt file.
Now what this
sitemap file does for us
is it's a list of the URLs
that you want crawled, right?
It's not stuff--
it's not duplicate content
or any of that.
And we'll actually
use this file
to feed those URLs
to our crawler,
and then it will
then be processed.
So it maximizes
your chances of being crawled
if you create a sitemap.
But--do you
understand that?
Part of it? Okay.
But the reason why I didn't
talk about it as much here--
I kind of mentioned it--
is that it's no substitute
for good link architecture
and strong URL structure,
if that makes any sense.
So a lot of times
people are like,
"oh, I didn't really
link my stuff well,
but I have a sitemap."
You know, a sitemap is fine,
but we're actually still--
Once we get that list of URLs,
it comes to our crawl team,
and we have to prioritize
what should be crawled when.
We're not gonna say--
Especially if you're
a spammer or something, right?
"You gave us 30,000;
we'll go crawl them right now."
Doesn't happen like that.
Again we kind of apply
some algorithms to it,
try to be smart about it.
So it's best to have strong link
architecture within your site.
And it's also--
as a huge bonus,
is just to submit
a sitemap to us,
or to create one and put it
in your Robots.txt file,
and then it'll be
picked up automatically
by Google, Yahoo!
and Microsoft.
So it really maximizes
your chances
to be seen
by our crawler.
audience member:
Just to clarify this question,
so I've seen sites
where a sitemap
is not actually
intended for users,
but it looks like it was
just dynamically generated
to direct the crawler
in certain directions.
So sitemap creates--
has a lot of links and stuff.
So this thing
versus sitemap XML.
So what should I do?
Should I do this one, both,
or only a sitemap XML?
Ohye: I'm not sure what that one
exactly looks like,
but a sitemap XML file
for sure will be picked up,
especially if you declare it
in your Robots.txt
or you submit it
through Webmaster Tools.
So the safe answer
is to do a sitemap XML file,
'cause that's
the standard for us.
Okay, so back
to these 404s.
This was ugly. I don't know
if you remember this.
This is Google
in the old days.
But in Webmaster Tools
in our Help Center,
we actually have
some JavaScript code.
And you just tell us
what language,
and we'll let you copy and paste
this code that you can apply
so that now you have
these friendly 404s.
So in the past
it just said, "Not found";
now with this code
you'll actually--
you might have closest matched
URLs that we found on your site.
You can also get a link back
to the home page,
a search box,
things like that.
And a link to your
sitemap file too.
So again, you know, a 404 is not
a great experience for a user,
it's gonna happen, but when it
does, give them some other way
to stay on your site and find
what they were looking for.
All right, so now
engaging the community.
This part is, you know,
kind of all the social media
stuff you've been hearing about.
First I just want
to give you this quote.
This is from Clay Shirky, from
his book, Here Comes Everybody.
He says...
Right, so this is
all about building
and engaging
his community.
So if you want to use a blog,
how do you do this?
Well, a good thing to do is not
just to put anything out there,
actually to become an authority,
someone people look to,
someplace that people go
to read your articles.
Use categories
that are also keywords.
That's important too.
And of course
keep your blog secure.
Blogs are easily hacked,
it's kind of becoming
on the increase as well.
And know that we give you
hackable software warnings
in Webmaster Tools.
Again, we're trying
to communicate more with you
about how you can
better your site.
So I could list
a whole bunch of things here,
but I actually just
give you this query term.
If you query
"matt cutts seo blogging tips"--
he's this guy we work with,
he's great.
He actually will give you
a whole bunch more
that you can look at.
So let's go
to some FAQs.
You might be asking,
"All right, should I publish
my full content,
or just a snippet
of my blog?"
Well, it's your
own preference.
Obviously if you want to do
something with analytics.
But from Google's perspective it
doesn't make a huge difference.
It's mildly better if we see
the full content first,
but you could do
what you like.
Just having been
to a lot of conferences
where we talk
about stuff like this,
most users do prefer
to see the full content.
But again,
it's your choice.
People also ask about duplicate
content on their blogs.
"I have an archive link,
"and then it lists
all the same blog posts,
"but now with
a different URL.
Can I Robots.txt
that out?"
And the answer
is yes, of course.
Again, just be careful and
make sure you do it properly,
but go ahead.
So if you're asking this,
what about tweets, right?
Good question.
Well, unlike blogs
that use ping services
to let everyone know when
a new blog has been published,
to let the search
engines know,
Twitter doesn't
do the same thing.
There's no ping service.
So of course we will
index tweets if we see them,
but it has to be--currently--
linked to on the Web.
So if it's linked to,
then it can be found, crawled,
and indexed, and returned
in search results,
but it's not
that automatic process
that you see often
with blogs.
All right, so also when you
want to engage the community,
you might be thinking
about comments and reviews.
So some of
the benefits of this
is that it can help your users
make an informed decision.
It also helps them communicate
with you with comments,
or communicate
with each other.
But just know
if you do want comments,
I'd host it
on your own site
rather than have them
go to some third party
where they might then engage
in this third-party site, right?
'Cause a lot of it
you're doing for engagement.
So while there are third-party
comment sites out there,
it's probably something you'll
want to do within your site.
This is for kind of
search-friendly reasons,
and also
for user stickiness.
Oh, but you do need
to moderate for spam.
Next, also,
if you do reviews.
Let's say you want to sell
women's high heels,
and you've got reviews
of women saying,
"Oh, this doesn't
pinch my toes,"
or, like, "I could run
in this or play basketball."
That's terrific, but what you
want to do is keep those reviews
on the same page
as your main product.
So they don't go to a separate
URL to see that review
because now you've got
this product description
of high heels,
but then you have
people commenting over here.
You really want to put
all that content
that's relevant
to that product on one page.
So when people link and say,
"Oh, I love this--
"you know, I just added
some comments here.
I love this product," and they
share it with their friends,
it's only that one URL
that's being
shared around
and linked to.
It's not these
two separate URLs.
So comments I'd usually keep
on the same product page.
Also when
it comes to reviews,
you might've seen
this announcement.
At developer conferences
I always get asked
about microformats.
So now I have an answer.
We just released rich snippets,
and what this does
is take sites
that are based on reviews,
or descriptions of people
which are set
at social networking sites,
and if they're
marked up--
Something happened to my slide;
looks kind of funny.
But if they're
marked up in RDFa,
or with a microformat review
or hCard,
we can actually
show that here.
So you can see
that snippet now has stars
for the rating
as well as price range.
So that's done
through microformats.
We're looking
to expand that as well.
Okay, so about
engaging the community,
what can you do
through Webmaster Tools?
Of course you could
check your backlinks.
This is a good way to see
who's linking to you,
you can find out
who your fans are.
So you might realize you have
audiences you never knew about.
If I'm selling
high heels,
I'm thinking my audience
is primarily women,
it might actually
be the case that there's
a lot of men out there,
you know, in these--
GQ or something
that are like,
"Actually, this is
the new fashion."
And if I start
to check my backlinks,
you know,
see my server logs,
that's where I could
start to find out
who's linking to me
and where they're linking to.
The next part about this is
just to maximize your traffic.
And Webmaster Tools will
show you up to 100 queries now
of the queries that brought
your site up in search results,
which are
the impressions,
as well as the actual results
that people clicked on.
And we'll show that
for seven days,
two weeks,
or different months.
So again that's
a lot of data here.
And you can use that
to actually maximize
what you're getting
impressions for
and make sure you
get that clickthrough.
So here's another way, you know,
to understand your community
and figure out ways to give them
more of what they want.
I wanted to end this
presentation with this question.
So it's our pop quiz.
"Do you think
it's better--"
I was actually asked this
at an SEO developer meet-up.
[reads]
So I'll let you think
about that for a few seconds.
Okay.
So what I think this person's
asking is essentially--
if you take it
to extremes--
she was asking,
"Would it be better to have
the number one ranking--"
or something,
you know,
she could think
in terms of these, like,
"Is it better to have the number
one ranking for this keyword,
or is it better to have
hundreds of followers?"
You know, you're kind of looking
at it two different ways.
But I think what
you actually need to do,
and that's why
I like this question,
is just take a step back.
Okay, 'cause we're not
just talking about rankings,
and we're not just
talking about followers.
What you actually probably want
on your site is conversions.
Right, it's not just
getting that traffic,
it's making a conversion.
That conversion
can be anything.
It can be purchasing
a microwave,
it can be hiring you
as a freelance developer,
right, there's a lot
of things you might want--
signing up
for a newsletter.
But--So if you
look at that--
So what you actually
probably want is a conversion.
That's the ultimate goal.
And how do people
make conversions?
Well, kind of using
pseudo-psychology,
I would say a lot of people
make conversions
when they feel that they're
well-informed and comfortable.
Okay?
And where they kind of
get some of this information
is either from their friends,
like in social media,
where they heard about you or
they heard about your microwave,
or they just kind of did
a search and found your site.
Right, so there's still
these two places where they can
get information and then
make that conversion.
But I would say
that most importantly,
people want to feel comfortable,
they often research,
and when they research they
often
go through a search engine
to find your site,
or they'll
come onto your site
and actually
read more about you.
So while they might
hear about you
through some social
media network, or, you know,
they might hear
about you through a tweet,
what they're probably gonna do
in the end is want to know more,
and that's gonna usually
come through your site itself.
So when it comes
to this question
about creating a site
or working in social media,
I'm kind of old school,
and I also work at Google,
so I'm obviously biased,
but I think if you create a site
that's helpful to users,
it's accessible
on multiple platforms,
whether it's a desktop
or it's a mobile phone,
and you make it easily found
by search engines,
then I think that's
gonna give you
the best kind
of conversion campaign
and really help
your business plan.
Okay?
So that's all
I have for today.
So I hope you can take
all these tips, get out there,
and really, you know,
make your site great.
So thank you very much.
[applause]